I our YouTube I'm Mel young i'm here at
the World Economic Forum at Davos I'm
homeless drunk up I'm often asked here
whether the weather more pessimistic or
optimistic and I'm optimistic because I
think although the world has problems
economically there's lots of ways out
that's what you've changed me I news
about conference here we are working in
particular sport and I think it's a huge
opportunity for the values of sport
which are about teamwork togetherness I
willingness to to achieve victory in
adversity a linked with a understanding
the sport has a sizable chunk of the
industry in the world he's two percent
of GDP normally so I think sport in such
a look at it not only in terms of its
value either an industry or in terms of
the values that the arts and apply these
across all sections in South America so
I'm optimistic very few